hi and welcome to episode number 35 of
the weekly Google club pass from podcast
hi I'm Francis component and I'm here
with my colleague mark Mendel hey Mark
hey Francesca you doing today we weren't
great very excited about our interview
with a shredder off and Morgan McLain
yeah I think it's going to be a really
nice continuation of the conversation we
had about struck driver with other yeah
I think it's going to be a nice
extension of that people gonna learn a
lot yeah previous episode basically we
covered how do you know if something's
wrong today we're going to be talking
about how do you know what is wrong yeah
how do you go about fixing it and
working out what's going on there yeah
and at the end we're going to be talking
about environment variables and 12
factura than not will factor application
it'll factor authentication that differ
yeah that's very scary they'll affect
our applications and how do you do those
on Google cloud platform yeah but before
that we have not one cool thing of the
week but true cool things of the week
you insisted on putting that second one
in your you were very insistent about it
yes because i think is actually pretty
cool it is a very short thing but
actually let's leave that for the second
one so yeah let's create some mystery in
history yes so so the first one comes
from our colleague Paul Newsome he's in
a rotation so he's normally a developer
advocate yeah but he's doing a rotation
as an SRE a site reliability engineer
exactly and it is it is a pre amazing
thing to do he's learning a lot and the
best part is that he wrote about it he
wrote a blog post it's called adventures
in a sri LAN welcome to google Mission
Control which sounds pretty epic and it
is indeed pretty epic he describes a
little bit what he's been doing for the
last couple months and basically why why
it is so cool it's really cool because
he's going to do a series of blog posts
sort of outlining and documenting his
experiences being a reliability engineer
and I think also we might we might have
him on the podcast at some point soon I
think he might have agreed to that yeah
yes the Americans from chasing involves
we may have had to lock him down but we
got him yeah probably he's busy doing
something like maintaining the stability
of the cloud 9i now so not important
yeah not as important a podcast
obviously yep anyway so we're looking
forward to get to have pole in the
pockets very excited about that and the
second cool thing of the week it is a
pretty short video is around five
minutes and an hour dear friend mouths
word head of solution for Google cloud
platform describes what Google cloud
platform is and how is it part of Google
and how Google why google has a cloud
and it is a very short video is only
five minutes but if your curves about it
I think it's a very interesting one it
covers many things like machine learning
and things like that so just have a look
the link is on the show notes absolutely
wonderful great so I guess it's time to
go talk with our friends share a trough
and Morgan McLain sounds like fun so we
are joined today by two product managers
who work on google cloud Sharat sheriff
and Morgan McLain how are you both doing
today doing good thanks doing great yeah
wonderful wonderful so the standard
question we ask everyone when they come
on the podcast is who are you what's
your history what do you get up to here
at Google Charette why don't we start
with you sure I'm sure a trough I am a
product manager working on developer
infrastructure on Google Cloud what that
really means is that I'm extremely
interested in developer workflows hub
developer write code how the ship code
how did they diagnose your application
how the debug it and so on I'm right now
focused a lot on application level
diagnostics and monitoring cool and
yourself Morgan yes I'm Morgan McLain
i'm also a product manager i'm on
stackdriver trace and like Sharad you
know I have a big interest in in
software Diagnostics I previously worked
on cloud services at other companies and
trace really excites me because it both
gives you a view of how your application
is running and what services are talking
to which other services and you can also
see you know
really interesting details about latency
or you know other unique insights into
how your your web application works cool
so recently we had an episode we talk
with our colleague as a ham early and we
discussed AG driver as a monitoring tool
but now when you introduce yourself you
use these other word diagnosis could you
tell us a little bit about what is
diagnosis and how is it different to
monitoring got it so when when as I
talked spoke about stackdriver she spoke
she covered a lot of the system and
infrastructure monitoring pieces and
this is basically telling the users
typically in that case ops or DevOps are
our developers how how their
infrastructure is behaving at any given
time at one specific time what Morgan
and I are focused on is basically around
when the user knows that they have a
problem in their application how do they
go about finding the root cause of the
problem so all the various tools that
you need to discover exactly where the
problem is occurring and why the problem
is occurring that's where we are really
focused on today tools yeah I think it
would be fair to say that one is more
ops focused I'd be like stackdriver
monitoring and alerting it tells you
when something's wrong and it tells you
from a very high level perspective what
is wrong and what's failing and the
diagnostic tools like trace and and
error reporting and debug can be used to
actually find out you know in your code
or in your architecture the root cause
of the problem so you can fix it and and
the other way to think of it is these
are effectively two sides of the same
puzzle so when when you have a problem
with your software you kind of look at
it in two different places that are
problem in my system or is the problem
in my application and based on that you
need different tools you need different
tools to find out why and where the
problem is
and and so much of what we are talking
about is around is at the application
level which tends to be written which is
basically around how do you connect the
code to what is actually happening in
production yeah alright cool so I guess
at a high level what tools are available
like something say something goes wrong
I've got I don't know I'm getting errors
in my code where does that lead me to
within size stackdriver so that we've
got today we have got a few tools that
are out there that's that users can
actually use logging of course is what i
consider logging is logging is a one
place the one tool that every
application developer can use if they
don't have any of the tools available
you can always go to logging because you
can always go back to your code
instrument your code to output something
two logs and then go back and look at
logs you can probably build some kind of
an automation to scrape through logs and
so on and so forth or even better the
one really cool feature that exists
today in stackdriver is to take the logs
out put it to export it to bigquery and
you then have the full power of bigquery
to analyze your logs so that is always
there in addition to logs we have some
tools like trace and Morgan can tell you
a lot about trays we have error
reporting which basically if you think
of trays as the is is the view of the
application from a latency point of view
error reporting is really about is
really looking at your application
errors no matter where they are
occurring and be able to analyze your
application almost instantly and then
you have the fourth stool that you have
available is the debugger stackdriver
debugger which effectively takes a
snapshot of your application at one time
it doesn't pause the application
anything it almost at runtime takes a
snapshot of your application and allows
you to inspect the state of the
application as the application is
serving out requests so those are the
tools that you have today there is more
coming coming online but this is the
four
I can talk about right now excellent
alright cool so i don't know let's maybe
let's take a couple of scenarios and
kind of talk through them and see and
see what tools we end up so okay so the
classic example i guess is i'm getting
an error on my application where does
that go maybe does it does it go to
logging does it automatically get caught
by error reporting I've written some
code in my app but I don't know where
does where does that information go to
and how can i find it how can i how can
i know something bad has happened yeah
so arrows can manifest in a couple of
different ways right one sure place
where it will manifest is in logs yep
but error reporting is always scraping
through logs so with the moment the
moment you have an application and App
Engine there is no setup needed at all
by the way for any of these tools you
don't there is no additional step of
integrating into agents integrating
agents anything like that if you have an
app engine application boom error
reporting will work for you and the
moment you have your application and it
starts throwing out some kind of errors
stackdriver error reporting will be able
to immediately one identify that it's a
new type of error and alert you that an
error has occurred and three give you
more statistics about that error itself
how often that error is occurring is it
80 it can give you a distribution of the
terror it's happening like 10 times
second or 10 times a week or whatever it
is you have all the statistics available
just by going to one URL so you would
get notified so in this scenario that
you describe you would see a
notification that tells you that hey
there's a new error or that has occurred
and then you would basically go in and
click on that link and you would then
get all the details about that error
including capturing the call stack so
you will basically associate it with
that error we capture the entire call
stack not only do we capture the call
stack we actually passed through the
call stack and identify the areas which
is most likely of interest because we
look at the call stack whenever I look
at a call stack it
eyes kind of glazed over because it's a
huge it's it's insane right you got so
what error reporting does really well is
basically says okay great we be of
assistance with the call stack here are
these five lines that you need to really
look at and you have everything else
available if you want to but it
basically hints to the user saying we
have the five lines that you got to look
at it and what I found part of the
beauty is that driver and the stack
driver suite of tools in situations like
this where maybe there's an error
occurring your application so you
flighted an error reporting or you'd be
notified that there's very high latency
in your application you can actually
jump between the tools right so in the
experience for error reporting I believe
you can launch the debug in trace for
example if you find a very high latency
trace you can launch into the logs for
those traces and so it's not so much a
collection of products that you're using
or collection of sort of four different
features that stackdriver offered to you
it's really a suite for Diagnostics
right and so even once you isolate the
problem with one of the lenses in that
suite whether that be logging or error
reporting you can then follow up and get
more analysis from some of the other the
other functionality that we offer yeah I
think Morgan brings up a really
interesting point here and a really
valuable point if we were going about
building tools we'll just keep churning
our tools yeah but the real thing is
we're really focused on developer DevOps
workflows it's really understanding okay
and something bad is happening with your
application and you will be notified or
should we when should we notify you and
where you're being notified we kind of
are we aspire to hold your hands right
from the point where you first get that
notification and take you all the way to
where the problem is occurring while at
the same time corralling information
from the application from the user in
cells as they are navigating through
this journey and from the systems when
we have it which is why we're all under
stackdriver and where possible the
applications customers applications
users so in appengine for example error
reporting can tell you how many
customers have been impacted nice by
this specific error so it's it
yeah we try to combine all this
information in order to help you do two
things find you bring you to the root
cause and help you prioritize like is it
you know do I need to drop everything
and immediately jump in right now or
okay this is something that it can wait
wait in address later yeah in some cases
or even suggestions on how to fix it
yeah cool so that means I guess I could
get an error notification through error
notifications that could then make me go
look at some logs maybe from there as
well I could jump into either trace or
debug yeah I can sign of jump around as
necessary to see where that that things
happening yep and there's further
integration coming in you know as we
keep building cool there's a step that
ain't kind of missing out though which
is so you say that you can jump directly
from from the error reporting to the
code how is the code link to your
project could you talk a little bit
about that is it how do I do that yeah
so the the place that the linkage point
occurs typically at the call stack level
where we basically show you a line
number filename at a line number and if
the user or if the project has has the
source code linked to the applicator
then then we can actually do this and a
couple of three different sources right
now three different repos that we
support of course it's a google cloud
repository so if your code is hosted in
Google Google's cloud repo then we are
able to from the call stack infer the
correct version of the application code
and and basically allows you to navigate
directly from the call stack to the
application code and with one click
allow you to take a snapshot and we'll
talk a little describe a little bit
later about what the snapshot really
does but in addition to that if your
code resides in github or bitbucket then
you can link it's a very straightforward
way to link your code that resides in
github repo or bitbucket but the moment
you do that then the cloud I mean
stackdriver debugger will very easily be
able to
to navigate to the source that's one of
the I guess the the magic sauce that
that that exists in all of this so
that's that sounds really interesting
are there any limitations that people
should be aware of maybe by either
language or it only works in certain
products right now much of what we're
talking about works very well for almost
all the major languages in App Engine we
are very rapidly building out the same
kind of support for compute and
container engine and and in compute
engine you'll see the matrix the
language support matrix is not
necessarily consistent between trays and
debugger and error reporting but we are
very we are in the matter of let's say
months I think it'll trace weeks yeah we
will have more and more support we
weren't lucky down two timelines I
wouldn't want to do that to you I
understand yeah but in certainly in the
the upcoming quarter and the quarter
following it's at least for trait i can
speak specifically for trace but i
believe it's true for the others is that
that support for GC and GK is is our top
priority because the experience an app
engine is excellent for stackdriver and
we want to make sure that the experience
is excellent on those other compute
platforms and just so we're clear to is
that both App Engine standard and
flexible or I think that does happen to
stand over now ok cool all right so I'll
ask the question I guess from the
different perspectives say I'm a
developer i'm working on google cloud
platform is there anything that I can do
to like put in place these practices
before like as I'm building my
application is there like tools or
agents or anything that I should be
doing sort of from the outset for some
of those things more like GCE or other
stuff yes so I know this touches on a
previous point if you're using App
Engine of course you're getting all this
functionality for free yeah basically
right like the beauty of it is that you
don't have to think ahead you don't have
to start linking libraries or go to a
third-party solution or anything like
that
if you're a developer have run GC or gke
then you should look for simple
libraries that we offer right for
example if you just go and spin up a vm
on GCE and and don't do any additional
work you're not going to trace won't
receive any data from your application
and you'll go to the trace panel on the
cloud console and you won't you know you
won't see any traces because we didn't
capture any but if you look at the trace
documentation on the Google cloud
platform website we have links there to
our java library in a nodejs library for
trace links for python and go should be
arriving shortly and those are libraries
that you can integrate with your code
and depending on the library and how
depending on on when you're listening to
this will have different levels of
support but but as already today if
you're using the nodejs library for
example you link the library you get it
to ren p.m. in your application and
suddenly you're collecting traces some
of the other ones like Jabba the initial
release you'll have to sprinkle it
throughout your code and so it's not
just linking it there's a little more
work than that and so that is something
you should think about while you're
developing we hope to move beyond that
the future but that's where we are today
so yeah if you're on GC ejike and you're
using java or language of the node and
you want to use trace and i think some
of the other features you should be
thinking about this you should be
thinking about the telemetry that you
want to collect the instrumentation that
you want to send us and that we can
provide to you and focus on what's the
most use what's most useful if trace is
very useful to you then you should go
useful to those libraries and sprinkle
it in yeah I think much of what Morgan
said applies to debugger and edit
reporting except the languages that
we're that are fleshed out are different
yeah d but God a few languages supports
a few languages in DC they're all going
at their own different paces but in the
matter of months we'll be at a point
where will we would have covered all the
major languages but the the other facet
of the question that you just asked is
is other AP is and correct me if I'm
wrong so other API is that developers
can use to leverage the functionality
that comes with say trace or debugger or
in reporting so that they can
incorporated in their existing workflow
the dashboard and and that is already
there so almost all the so everything
from logging trays debugger and
reporting all of these have AP is it's
all available through the one platform
api so if you want to be able to extract
traces all right races we will talk
about right as well but if you want to
extract any of this data so that you can
host it in your own dashboard you can do
that and and so that that's something to
think about as well yeah or if you want
to submit data to those services but
perhaps we haven't provided a library
yet you're certainly welcome to do so
through those api's yeah i mean if you
think of the example where not
everything is traditional request
responses right so you could have you
could say you could have a scenario
where a developer is trying to diagnose
latency of one specific function that he
or she is written down so you have the
ability to say here is a customs I mean
here's a custom span that and i would
like to capture and you insert a start
time and an end time that is not
something that is automatically
instrumented for you but but developer
can do it so she or he can basically say
here is the custom start in the custom
stop and have this whole thing span
represented in the context of my entire
request so they can say this function
adds X milliseconds to my overall
request yeah and I would be useful even
if you're on App Engine if you're
calling like an external service or
something your instrumented otherwise
you can still submit that data through
the API yeah and ending and you can do
all of that using that API that exists
that we're talking to you so what you
were talking about now made me think
about these uses which is I have one new
version of my of my code and I want to
make sure if it's faster or slower mmm
how how could I go to do that yeah so I
think you probably want to start in
trace because this is primarily latency
analysis and trace actually has some
pretty unique features that allow you to
do this so in the past or if you're
using other tools like what you might do
is take a coal
traces before and after with the
different versions and do a manual
comparison and may probably eyeball it
and see if the latency has changed but
trace has a feature called analysis
reports that will do this for you both
automatically or you can create custom
ones so every day if you're submitting
data for trace whether that's because
you've an app engine application or
you're submitting it through one of our
libraries or through the trays API every
day we go and do comparisons day by day
in version by version of the latency of
your application so let's say you rolled
out a new version and you didn't do it
take any additional actions next time
you go to the cloud console you'll see
that there's actually a comparison in
that section of the Tracy line that did
a comparison day by day and if the
latency is significantly changed either
for the bet for better or for worse but
if the profile of latency has changed we
will both alert you and give you sample
traces that let you do that comparison
for yourself secondly if you want to do
a manual report which you can do
immediately right so you don't have to
wait for the next automated one to come
through you can you can trigger a manual
report to do either a version by version
comparison or a time comparison let's
say you could compare yesterday's traces
to all the traces collected over the
last month on average and it'll run that
same analysis report for you until you
if there's been a significant change in
the profile of latency for your
application or for particular component
of your application right you could do
it / endpoint or something like that if
you've micra services architecture and
it'll also once again give you those
sample traces so you can actually get
examples and you maybe click through and
a few and go oh you know maybe the
database or something slowed up slow
down after we rolled the version forward
or calls to this service slowed down and
so you can actually very rapidly isolate
what changed and and you know that this
then you can use that to jump in other
tools like debug to find out
specifically why it changed and an error
reporting as well is version aware so
the moment you push out a new version
and and a new kind of error or a new era
starts occurring it's automatically
capture and you always had the ability
to write right there on the top you can
filter out you can filter down by
version so you can say here does the
version area where should be but
the it's good to also highlight at this
point the the underlying emphasis on
trying to remove some of the some of the
operational friction where we would
prefer we would like to remove some of
these this what i would call grunt work
so that developers can focus all their
effort on creating while Google's got
got their back right basically we will
always when you when when and you up
when a new version rolls out will be
aware of it and not really will will be
aware of it will always compare it with
what's happening with your previous
version and if we see significant amount
of divergence in any of these four
that's latency or availability or errors
will immediately surface it up we will
always be able to take link those errors
to the right version of your code so
that we can allow you to kind of very
quickly navigate through to the problem
great well we're kind of running out of
time but what could you recommend for
our listeners if they done if they have
never tried any of the stack driver
features what is the first thing they
should they should do well if you're an
app engine you should just go use it
like like you know we have a pretty good
adoption on App Engine but like there's
no reason to not use stackdriver on App
Engine because you get all these tools
for free we're already collecting
instrumentation data it's it's you know
if you have a large you know important
set of applications on App Engine you
should go try out the stack drivers
suite immediately and I think you'll
find that it's really useful great yeah
the the other thing I would emphasize is
we did it's only by just but just it's
as simple as clicking through to a tab
on the cloud console and you'll be able
to see it's all under the operations tab
grouped group yeah and you'll just be
able to click on it and everything
should be working and once you do that
everything else is just turned on
automatically for App Engine standard
and and we will currently have the same
level of focus to
minimal amount of setup needed so that
users can use that when we have the same
offerings available in compute and
containers and everyone else so yes we
are we are running out of time just a
little bit but is there anything else
you'd like to add the we have any of the
colored or maybe haven't mentioned or
something you'd like to plug about
stackdriver or stackdriver diagnostic
stuff yeah so the the one thing that I
want to emphasize is all the all the
features that you that you hear about in
Diagnostics with its logging or trays
debug error reporting all of these
features that we enable completely
automatically out of the box we are
obsessive about about the about
performance of the overall application
itself what I mean by that is the the
footprint that we that we use in order
to do this we basically except that is
added to these applications in order to
capture all this Diagnostics is as in
the order of microseconds or
single-digit milliseconds is the way to
think of it so so so we've always we
want to make sure that we are not adding
an additional burden to the application
itself the second thing is we basically
every one of these things that we
capture every one of this piece of
information we capture is is basically
curated is is basically analyzed by by
some of our by some of our algorithms
here one example to think of as trace
insights right we have about a billion
traces of more than a billion traces
easily more than a million traces coming
in into our system every day each one of
these phrases is is analyzed for points
of two to identify points of suboptimal
T within that so that we can actually
say hey you're making too many data so
next time or yours memcache calls a very
slim cash call or something like that so
we identify every single trace so that
we can then provide surface all of that
information to the developer the third
thing to call out is is is if you if you
want to basically go from identifying
the problem alright
defying the location of a problem to the
root cause that isn't a better tool than
debugger the way to think of the
debugger is it basically I I think one
of one of the engineer engineers who
wrote this tool describes it really well
it's like taking an x-ray of a person
who is running without stopping the
person right you can see the internals
of the entire system I've got some of
the best stories around very interesting
bugs that debugger has uncovered just by
the ability to have a very detailed view
into the working of the application
without ever pausing this application so
it's like a snapshot it's a snapshot I
mean and to reproduce a similar
functionality it often takes developers
days one way to think of it is you know
very often if you're to debug and try to
find the root cause of a problem you
would go you go instrument some lines of
code B word again go through the
validation and deploy it again go back
and analyze the code again do this thing
multiple times until you've probably
found the right thing with debugger
wherever the problem is occurring even
if it's happening in production no
problem just click take a snapshot boom
you're very quickly be able to say ah
there is a race condition that I didn't
see you don't have to reproduce that
anywhere in a test environment is a real
power interruption right and and that
that this is spectacular when customers
use it and I hear the the wow so it's
very exciting for us building this tools
and correct me if i'm wrong i think that
actually works across App Engine and GC
and Jackie favorite many GC languages
all yeah so many of this is available in
GC intiki as well awesome well yeah like
I said I think we are running out of
time so I think we're gonna have to cut
it there but thank you very much to both
of you for joining us who really
appreciate it you're very welcome thank
you for having us thank you thank you
folks thence again through the sheriff
and Morgan McLain for sharing their very
deep knowledge on stackdriver and
especially on the Diagnostics by
of it I I discovered many different
tools that i'm gonna be using next time
i have an issue i'm not looking forward
to having any issues but for an exam and
know what to do yeah now I actually kind
of wanted to sit down with debugger now
and just kind of just poke at my up and
just see what it's doing like just a
given point in time I had some fun with
the with the debugger and I gotta say
it's pretty impressive but basically
instead of just adding more and more
logs which is normally what I do that's
how I did rather than just logging every
single value in your function you just
put a little break point and you don't
actually stop it so it is also great
yeah perfect so let's go with a question
of the week yeah you you post a really
interesting when we were sitting here
earlier yeah so the question of the week
is ok so I've been reading about 12
factor not authentication and candidate
I tell factor applications yep and by
the way if you don't know what they are
uh you should just search that on google
and read a little bit about it but put
in the Senate yeah one of the things
that the 12 factor application manifesto
says is that you should always deploy
basically the same artifact everywhere
so the same compiled binary or the same
docker image or whatever you're doing
and the differences between QA and test
and production should be done with
environment variables so the question is
how do you do that how do you do
environment variables Google cloud
platform yeah and there's a few
different ways you can do it depending
on which product you're on yeah
basically so depending if you have tce
GAE in TKE so if you have say that three
times quickly no I cannot do that I'm /
surprised I did once so on App Engine
there's actually a thing called
environment variables yep so you can set
them very easily inside of a pajama or
ab dot XML depending on the language of
using and basically it allows you to say
hey you know like the variable name I
don't know another host that's a bad
idea but like let's go advice yoda base
URL equals something and then when you
access it from your app engine code it
actually looks like it's an environment
variable yep so every language has
different ways upside
accessing those but basically there will
be behaved like any other environment
variable so what about on gk on
container engine so ji ka you have a few
options quite similarly the sort of app
engine when you're sending your yamo
files or your configuration up to your
doctor containers or up to gk itself up
to cooper Nettie's you can explicitly
set environment variables in that ml
file but if you want something that's
maybe a little bit less coupled a little
bit more flexible you can do things like
config maps or secrets those are ways to
send up information up to communities
with a given name that can then be
looked up later those can be exposed in
a variety of ways from like volumes and
a variety of other things but one of the
ways you can do that is sending up data
as environment variables secrets tend to
be used when you've got like private
information like usernames and passwords
config naps are used when you sort of
have tech stuff like maybe where is my
database point of that or maybe where is
the URL for my mailing list or maybe
it's just like hey this is the version
of this app that I want to display it's
got a blue button rather than a red one
less sensitive stuff so you have a have
a variety of options there cool now on
compute engine so if I'm running just a
straight-up vm is there an option that i
can use there so one of the things that
you can imagine is you login into your
instance and you just set it said the
environment variable there whatever OSU
running so let's say you're using Linux
you go export whatever equals whatever
and that will work but next time you
start a new instance a new instance that
we will not have those values so how do
you do it if you want to set those
environment variables across all your
instances oh yeah well the best way is
actually using the metadata server made
it there a server API and it is just a
key value store so it is very simple and
whenever you're gonna set a new one it
all the instances that already running
will have access automatically to that
value so it can be very useful for if
you're doing something like the database
like a link to the database and if at
any point you need to change that you
just change it and if your code is
regularly checking that variable out it
will everything will just work
it is also completely safe so you can
store secrets if you want to next it is
encrypted so there's no problem with
that and finally the cool thing is that
this will actually work anywhere so you
can access those those variables from
from compute engine obviously yeah but
also from App Engine and compute and
container engine now do I need to like
call an API to do that or is that just
inherently available so if you're an app
engine you need to use an API it is very
simple it's only a REST API so and i'm
almost sure there's a library for that
yep but even if there was not it's
basically as i get it's a get request on
to a URL that is only accessible from
inside google cloud platform so guessing
you have access yeah I can do exactly
the same thing from a docker container
inside JK exactly perfect yeah it is it
is very simple but isn't quite apart
incredibly powerful and you can use it
from anywhere in your project so it
makes it for a very easy way to
integrate different pieces of your
architecture now that's cool so if i
wanted to share say some information
across an app engine and gke and maybe a
gte project that i wanted to stay the
same across all of them that could be my
central location for so the other server
api it's gonna be the best place yes
very nice excellent okay well Francesca
are you gonna be anywhere fun and
interesting in the next coming weeks I
know you're relaxing now it good for
Kanye's over yes go for cone is over the
videos will be up sometime soon and in
the meanwhile I'm going to be chilling
on the beach soon but don't worry we're
gonna be having episodes non-stop
there's no break there's no break i'll
be just somewhere enjoying the beach but
in the meanwhile ah yeah I don't have
any interesting plans to share which is
awesome I think that your kids little
bit different yeah so I had some things
sort of cooking in the fire for a while
and they've come to fruition so yeah
when this comes out the week after that
I will be in Israel I'm doing multiple
events in Israel so i am going to the
GDG cloud Tel Aviv meet up i'll be there
on the twenty-fifth the day after that i
will be at javascript
Israel on the 26 that evening and the
main event I'm coming up for is game is
they have a development day talking
about game development may be showing
some fire based content often there so
I'm going to be running all over the
place in Israel nice nice after that I'm
taking a bit of a vacation yeah like I
said we've got podcast episodes very
well-deserved vacation great well thank
you so much I have a good trip thank you
and see you all next week see you all
next week
you